until i hear something from odell
i'm not gonna come i mean
odell and my relationship is fine you
know
so
uh odell and adam's relationship is fine
i don't know what i mean i'm sorry i
don't think there's any
i'm sorry i don't think there's a like
any gotcha moment here
okay but
i can only tell you what i think
and what i've seen from odell and what
i've seen from odell is nothing like the
reports indicate
so
sorry
freddie kitchen's brown's head coach
talking to reporters on monday report
came out on sunday from jay glaser of
fox that beckham had said to opposing
players and coaches come get me charles
robinson of yahoo added some specificity
to that chris on monday by reporting
that it was during an october game they
played the 49er seahawks and patriots in
october that beckham said to opposing
players come get me meaning that he was
hoping it would happen before the 2019
trade deadline and you know what if
freddie kitchens is telling the truth
why the hell isn't he finding out what's
going on isn't there enough there to
cause you to get odo beckham jr and say
what's going on do we have a problem we
need to solve not they can do anything
about it now but i would at least be
curious from freddie kitchens if the
guy's saying one thing to me and saying
something else to opposing players and
coaches well 100 i think that's you know
a very valid question that you you posed
there yeah freddy kitchens john dorsey
especially i mean he's the guy that's
running the organization right now so
you want to check in with him just to
make sure yeah are you happy here
everything going the right way i know it
hasn't been a great year all those
things um
you know
out of those three things out of those
three teams you said it in october 49ers
seahawks patriots who do you think the
team is that he might have said that to
like if you had a guess
well you know somebody sent me a link
last night i haven't had a chance to
look at it yet because it was during the
game apparently there's audio of him
saying something like that to jimmy
garoppolo the 49ers quarterback wow okay
because i would have guessed you know
and of course we know the 49ers were
were fording with odell beckham jr and
the giants last offseason before the
browns trade happened you know as i've
said many times i know the patriots were
interested i don't think the seahawks
would be the team so that would cancel
them out i would think the patriots
would be that team uh now i'll be
interested to see what that little audio
clip says that it was sent to you but
you know the patriots at that time too
we're certainly having wide receiver
issues we know the love that odell
beckham jr has not only for the patriots
for tom brady the way they do things
there uh you know all i could say is you
know at this thing i just i hope odell
didn't do this or didn't say this i i
really don't it just doesn't look good
on him you know he's done a lot of
things uh in a good way this year as far
as handling himself not being too crazy
but has had some moments too where it's
raised eyebrows and we go like what the
heck come on that's not worth it either
don't do that uh he you know i just
think you know in cleveland there's
there's some support there there's a
future there's potential and i'm hoping
that he's willing to kind of hang in
there and make it work
yeah and and i i think it's a maturity
issue more than anything else right i
really do with otto beckham jr he's an
incredible talent
but
there's just that lack of self-awareness
there's lack of understanding it's been
there for a few years now
and i don't know that it would work for
him in new england i don't know that he
could deal with all the rules and
restrictions and the stripping away of
individuality that they expect in new
england and trust me if you don't show
up for otas you're gonna have a problem
with bill belichick but maybe he needs
that maybe that's the thing that will
mature him you know maybe deep down he
wants a task master he wants to be part
almost like going to boot camp like it's
going to make him into a more mature
better person over the long haul if he
has a high level of discipline being
imposed on him from the outside because
he's not imposing it on himself from the
inside i mean i don't want to
psychoanalyze him but i i think he's
craving that quality of an organization
and he's willing to take whatever is
required
to get to that level and i i don't think
we're going to see him with the browns
next year who do you think he plays for
week one 2020 oh if you made me choose
right now i'd say the new england
patriots that'd be the team i would look
at certainly you know and you know to
your point what if brady's not there
what if brady's not you know i still
think there's i still think i'd pick
them i would i know that the new england
patriots love the jared sidham kid that
they think the kid has a bright future
uh and you know again i i just think
that he would fit in with the offense
regardless it's it's of course very
dynamic in their approach and what they
do and they need that talent boost to
where he'd be the go-to guy and they
would formulate the offense around him
like they have had when they've had some
great receivers gronk randy moss wes
welker julian edelman whatever it may be
so it'll be interesting to see he's
still a tremendous talent who's fought
through you know some injury this year
and a bunch of weird circumstances there
in cleveland
and will the browns double down and try
to force it to work next year or will
they realize it's probably in everyone's
best interest to go their separate ways
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports